Robert Baratheon: Little Prince Lucerys must
have wet himself when he entered Storm's End
and found King Aegon's younger brother, Aemond,
already with Lord Baratheon.
Aemond was fearsome even before he lost his
eye and set a sapphire in its stead, but the
princeling pleaded his mother's case.
Finally, Lord Baratheon made his decision.
"Go home, pup, and tell the bitch, your mother,
that the Lord of Storm's End is not a dog
she can whistle on."
As Aemond's false eyed gleamed at him, the
princeling fled the castle and mounted his
young dragon Arrax.
The rain fell in sheets, and great bolts of
lightning lit the world bright as day.
Arrax was struggling to stay aloft in the
gale when a roar shook the very foundations
of Storm's End.
Aemond rose through the clouds and below him
the monstrous Vhagar.
Vhagar was five times the size of Arrax and
a hardened survivor of a hundred battles.
Vhagar caught him above Shipbreaker Bay.
Watchers on the castle walls saw distant blasts
of flame and heard a shriek drown out the
thunder.
Prince Lucerys fell, broken, to be swallowed
by the waves.
With his death, the war of ravens came to
an end, and the war of fire and blood began.